nom de zeus ils sont en train de
disparaître de la photo salut si on aime
bien comprendre les choses on est
forcément fasciné par la saga de retour
vers le futur alors c'est mon cas et
pour mon anniversaire j'ai eu la chance
de recevoir plein de goodies de la saga
vous avez pu en voir une partie si vous
me suivez sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui une voici quelques anecdotes
à savoir sur le film sur les films gêné
alors retour vers le futur au départ
c'était un seul film et ils ont pris la
décision d'en faire une trilogie au
moment où ils ont dû décider de faire un
deuxième film avait eu beaucoup de
succès le public le réclame et universal
leur a proposé son nid ok on fait une
trilogie ce qui était une bonne idée
puisque au niveau des scénarii ça
permettait de croiser un petit peu les
idées du troisième du deuxième et de les
relier au premier tout ce que j'ai écrit
dans cette vidéo je les valider dans le
livre qui est sorti sur l'histoire de la
saga
c'est un super livre sur toutes les
anecdotes autour du film sur les
journées tournage une par une il a reçu
le soutien de robert zemeckis et bob
bell et il a reçu leur validation
également pour ceux que ça intéresse je
vous mets le lien dans la description
comme dans la plupart des scénarii il ya
eu plusieurs versions dont trois
scénarios principaux et là il ya quand
même pas mal de choses qui changent au
départ doc n'a pas un chien mais un
ouistiti qui deviendra ensuite un
chimpanzé pour dire d'une manière
globale un singe ce qui sera refusé plus
tard pour devenir dans la version finale
un chien le convecteur temporel
également qui marche au nucléaire au
départ il marche est également au
nucléaire mais il manquait un ingrédient
quelque chose qui permettait même de
s'en passer et surtout de le faire mieux
fonctionner cet ingrédient dans le film
c'est marty qu'il découvrira essai du
coca et dans la toute première version
marty et doc devait partir vers le futur
pas du tout par le passé mais marty idée
qui va être détournés d'ailleurs dans le
numéro deux a une idée il se dit je vais
faire de l'argent avec ça et donc ils
programment la machine à voyager dans le
temps pour aller dans un passé proche
pour se donner lui même le résultat des
courses hippiques et gagner mais le vrai
grand changement qui a eu deux scénarios
un scénario c'est la fin du film
au tout début ça vous n'avez rien à voir
avec les clerc marty et doc partait au
nevada pour générer la réaction
nucléaire dans un centre d'essai
nucléaire ce qui fait qu'après marty
dans le futur se retrouvaient ans le vit
sous le sable dans le désert
et encore ce ne sont vraiment que
quelques détails que je suis en train de
vous donner ici c'est seulement de la
deuxième version du film dans le
deuxième scénario que le professeur
ahmed brand va devenir le docteur brand
docteur qui sera raccourcie en doc parce
qu'on avait peur à l'époque qu'on
confonde avec la boisson dr pepper et
l'anecdote croustillantes que je vous
garder un petit peu pour la fin des des
versions de scénario c'est qu'il faudra
attendre le troisième scénario celui qui
a servi de base à la version définitive
pour voir comme machine à voyager dans
le temps la delorean
ce n'était pas prévu au départ c'était
censé être une machine à voyager dans le
temps
il ya même eu un moment où ça
ressemblait plus à un frigo qu'autre
chose mais c'est bien après que c'est
devenu delorean ce qui change tous les
scénarios possibles puisque dans le iii
par exemple ils ont des problèmes
d'essence et ça c'est
directement lié au fait que ce soit une
voiture saviez vous que christopher
lloyd celui qui joue doc avait lu le
script n'était pas très emballé parce
qu'il avait des décisions à prendre dans
sa vie puis par rapport au théâtre et
est ce qu'il allait faire
professionnellement l'endroit où ils
allaient vivre etc
il a lu le script est il à jeter à la
corbeille ça n'a pas du tout emballé et
c'est sa femme sa femme de l'époque qui
a discuté avec lui pour lui rappeler
quelles étaient ses objectifs de départ
à lui professionnellement parlant et lui
vendre un peu les mérites de ce film
merci madame doc
mais le plus étonnant c'est que durant
les 28 premiers jours de tournage la
personne qui incarne et martin étaient
pas michael j fox s'était pas encore lui
nono nyon il était beaucoup trop occupés
pour incarner le rôle parce qu'il
tournait déjà à l'époque et c'est eric
stoltz
on va dire eric qui a endossé le rôle
mais au bout de 28 jours de tournage
quand il fait les pré montage zemeckis
n'est pas satisfait du tout du résultat
il trouve que ça ne marche pas il pense
que le public n'arrivera jamais à
s'identifier à lui que tous les autres
comédiens ça marche mais que l'un trucs
qui se passent pas avec eric qui
commence a contacté tout le monde pour
faire part de ses doutes et dire non il
faut que ce soit michael j.fox
absolument et il met tout d'un système
en place pour contacté son agent pour
essayer de le convaincre et à l'époque
comme il tournait comme je voulais dit
sacrée famille son agent gary avait même
pas pris la peine de l'en informer
il avait simplement refusé le projet
sans en parler à michael j.fox gary an
par l'ats michael j fox michael dit oui
grave j'aimerais trop faire ça et son
agent lui dis ok mais va falloir tourner
les deux en même temps il est hors de
question que tu arrêtes sacrée famille
donc durant tout le tournage michael
j.fox enchaîné la journée l'un le soir
l'autre il n'arrêtait jamais ce qui fait
qu'il n'a pas vécu pleinement le
tournage comme on pourrait s'y attendre
il n'avait pas une vision trop globale
de l'histoire
ils étaient toujours des phases et et
d'après ses dires c'est ce qui lui a
aussi permis dans le rôle d' avoir ce
côté un peu déphasé dumas qui passe
d'époque en époque c'est qu'ils le
vivent est réellement en fait donc quand
il a accepté zemeckis est allé voir le
patron d'universal pour essayer de lui
dire que s'il n'avait pas encore parlé à
universal de ça qu'il fallait jeter à la
poubelle les 28 premiers jours de
montage pour prendre un nouvel acteur le
patron de l'époque leur a juste posé une
question à leur ai dit est ce que vous
pensez que ça va changer quelque chose
de changé un acteur ils ont dit oui et
le patron indien
il n'empêche que dans le premier film de
retour vers le futur il reste encore des
images avec eric qui joue le rôle de
marty c'est surtout sur des plans larges
mais ça peut se trouver tous les détails
que je vous raconte ce ne sont que la
face visible de l'iceberg
l'histoire du film tel qu'on le connaît
aujourd'hui avec les acteurs qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui avec les visuels
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui est tellement
remplie de rebondissements
qu'on pourrait en faire un film bon
c'est une trilogie sur le paradoxe
temporel alors forcément il ya plein
d'hypothèses qui ont été faites un peu
partout moi aussi j'ai les miennes ou
des interrogations ou des choses sur
lesquelles on n'est pas forcément
d'accord parce que déjà il ya trois
hypothèses ya trois vraies hypothèses
sur la temporalité le voyage dans le
temps dans tous les films
celle de retour vers le futur et
s'appuie sur le fait que si on se change
quelque chose dans le passé alors le
futur change telle idée de l'effet
papillon mais moi il ya des petits
détails qui ne font pas forcément
sûrement que vous aussi
parmi les trucs qui me chagrine ya par
exemple dans le deuxième film quand ils
reviennent du futur de 2015 pour
retourner en 85 le 85 n'est plus le même
parce qu'il a changé par exemple on
apprend que deux brawn a été enfermé en
1983 donc s'il a été enfermé en 83 le
marty de 85 du premier film ne va pas
retourner dans le passé d'ailleurs été
plutôt malin de la part de biff de leurs
enfermé mais d'ailleurs s'il est enfermé
en 83 que la machine à voyager dans le
temps n'existe pas c'est à dire que le
futur beef ne pourra pas donner à
l'ancien beef l'almanarre je sais pas si
c'est très clair ce que je dis mais en
clair puisque beef de 2015 a changé le
son passé et donc le futur du bifff de
tout ce qu'il ya entre 85 et 2015
n'existe plus en tout cas plus sous la
même forme et ce qui est sûr c'est que
le bifff du futur n'ira jamais en 85
redonner sa bile du passé alors que
c'est une action nécessaire donc ça ce
sont des petites choses qui peuvent
m'empêcher de dormir par exemple encore
plus grave le doc de 85
celui qu'on voit dans le troisième film
qui va réparer la delorean qui a été
laissée depuis le far west
puisqu'il l'a réparé il connaît tous les
plans de la machine à voyager dans le
temps
il sait comment fonctionne pourquoi il
va remettre 30 ans alors reconstruire
maintenant il sait il ya plus besoin de
chercher c'est très simple pour lui on
me dirait que oui mais dans ces cas là
il ya plus de films oui c'est vrai mais
ça a le droit quand même de me prendre
un peu la tête
malgré tout c'est une saga que j'adore
c'était un grand plaisir pour moi de
vous parler un petit peu de retour vers
le futur même si je pourrais faire une
chaîne consacrée à un retour vers le
futur
j'adore ça merci d'avoir regardé la
vidéo si elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
laisser un petit live vous pouvez
également vous abonner à la chaîne avant
de partir et puis le mental box est
toujours une vidéo par jour pendant un
an du 1er janvier au 31 décembre donc
rendez vous demain on sera lundi à 17h
ciao
[Musique]